Зазвичай притока Дніпра річка Тетерів
навесні виходить з берегів.
Та не цього року. Без весняної повені
вона так і не наповнилась водою.
Течії майже немає, і подекуди вода стоїть,
ніби в озері.
Як наслідок -  бракує води
й у водосховищі "Відсічне".
Це рівень, через який  вода зазвичай
в цей весняний період
має переливатись.
Зараз Ви бачите, що рівень води
і дамби мають різницю
у півтора метра.
Андрій Нікітін, директор
"Житомирводоканалу", хвилюється.
Адже, якщо дощів не буде,
води вистачить на чотири місяці,
а далі місту доведеться вживати
жорстких заходів економії
та розраховувати на милість природи.
Для Житомира це загрожує
нестачею води для населення
і господарськопобутових потреб.
І це загрожжує погодинним
графіком постачання води.
Орієнтовно 7 годин з 24.
Та не лише Тетерів, але й решта
малих приток Дніпра
мають аномально низький рівень води.
Серед основних причин - те, що
за останні роки в Україні спостерігається
зміна режиму опадів: так, зими стали
майже безсніжні,
а влітку за кілька годин випадає
одна-дві місячні норми опадів.
Це не дозволяє річкам наповнитись.
Та до природних явищ додається ще людська діяльність,
кажуть в Українському
гідрометеорологічному інституті.
Це карта значущих джерел
антропогенного навантаження басейну Дніпра.
Червоні точки на карті - це міста та містечка.
В Україні головними забруднювачами річок
є житлово-комунальні господарства.
Майже всі міста користуються старими,
збудованими ще за радянських часів
очисними спорудами.
А деякі міста-десятитисячники, кажуть
в Інституті, взагалі їх не мають,
і скидають стоки в найближчу річку.
Науковиця занепокоєна тим, що через цьогорічний
низький рівень у водоймах
значно погіршиться якість питної води.
Ми теж це моделювали.
Якщо вплив стічних вод міст був
20-25%, при нормальній водності,
то в таких умовах він зростає до 80%.
Найбільш несприятлива ситуація буде,
де велике місто на березі малих річок.
У нас три таких больових точки:
це Харків - Уда, Лопань, це Полтва - Львів, і Устя - Рівне.
Там маленька річка, а міста великі.
Буде відповідно великий обсяг стічних вод
і органічне і біогенне забрудення буде високе
За даними ООН Україна вважається
маловодною країною.
Адже більшість водних ресурсів
країни через забруденість
не придатні для водозбору питної води.
Відповідно до Угоди про асоціацію з ЄС,
Україна зобов’язалася впровадити
шість водних Директив ЄС,
серед яких і директива про очистку міських стічних вод.
Це означає, що населені пункти
та промислові об'єкти
мають обов'язково очищати
та каналізувати стічні води.
Аби стимулювати підприємства до цього,
в Держводагенстві підготували зміни до законодавства.
Однак на втілення цих змін, відводять ціле десятиліття.
Якщо ми завтра скажемо комунальним
підприємствам і водоканалам,
що завтра ви повинні мати сучасні споруди,
де вони повинні ці гроші взяти?
Вони повинні нам з вами півищити
тариф на воду
і відповідно за рахунок нас з вами
збудувати очисні споруди.
І що ми будемо з вами казати,
якщо не дай боже
на 10 копійок збільшиться тариф
на гарячу чи холодну воду?
Ми почнемо кричати, що зрада,
і підемо десь мітингувати.
З часом, обіцяють у відомстві, мати
сучасні очисні споруди буде вигідніше,
аніж платити високі штрафи за скидання стоків.
Нині ж порушення екологічного законодавства
коштує не більше чашки кави.
Тож Житомир, де міська влада вже активно взялась
за будівництво очисних споруд,
є позитивним винятком з правила.
За німецькими стандартами
і на кошти Світового банку
тут вже зводять сучасний водоканал,
сподіваючись принаймні частково вирішити
проблему нестачі якісної питної води.
Більш поширеним явищем є сумний досвід,
про який розповідає депутат Ірпінської
міської ради Лаврентій Кухалейшвілі.
Корупційна влада нерідко
сама покриває порушників.
Так, замість того, щоб захищати
заплавні землі річки Ірпінь,
місцева влада дозволила побудувати на них житловий комплекс
на майже вісімдесят багатоповерхівок.
Законним шляхом на жаль я тут
робити нічого не можу,
депутатів всього 36,
адекватних всього чотири,
а більшість - це 19 депутатів.
Тобто для того, щоб мені
протистояти в правовому руслі,
мені треба більшість.
Половина депутатів у нас – забудовники,
і цю забудову веде мій "колега" …
Я тут вже 68 день з вагончиком,
і цей час забудова не ведеться.
Таких історій чимало по Україні:
природоохоронні водозахисні смуги забудовуються,
підприємства скидають в річки стічні води.
Недбало до води ставляться і мешканці сіл.
Залишають побутове сміття, яке потім потрапляє в річку.
Витрачатись на екологічні потреби ОТГ не поспішають.
Через невеликі бюджети покривають першочергові потреби,
як-от будівництво доріг, соціальної інфраструктури.
Утім, є поодинокі випадки, коли громади
беруться і за порятунок водойми.
Так береги річки Циганки,
яка протікає через села Баранівської ОТГ, що на Закарпатті,
виглядали до очистки від чагарників.
А так - нині.
Це, каже, сільський голова, рятує
навколишні будинки від повеней.
Минулого року ми розробили проектно-кошторисну документацію
на розчистку частини русла річки,
так як тут час від часу ставались повені
і береги були захаращені кущами, деревами.
Щоправда, коли йдеться про збереження річок,
окрім бажання й готовності
місцевої влади та громади діяти,
варто заручитися ще й підтримкою фахівців.
Розчистка річок, розумне відновлення течії -
це взагалі великий плюс,
потрібно цим займатись.
Інша річ: такі заходи мають проводитись
скажімо, без зайвого фанатизму,
щоб занадто не пошкодити екосистеми,
які там сформувались.
У нас є гарячий приклад по Дністру,
де планується днопоглиблення.
Воно начебто призначене,
щоб збільшити протічність річки
і збільшити глибину для проходження суден,
але таке днопоглиблення дуже сильно змінює
ситуацію в річці.
Вибираються донні відклади
і змінюються умови проживання водних організмів, які там є.
І після того екосистемі потрібні, як правило,
роки і десятки років, щоб відновитись.
Українцям, схоже, доведеться  не лише
звикати до примх природи,
які, на думку кліматологів, ставатимуть закономірністю,
але й на власному
досвіді переконатися,
що деякі природні
ресурси скінченні.
Тож берегти їх варто вже сьогодні.